maria
is in harrisburg pennsylvania hi maria
how are you
i'm good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so here's my situation i still live at
home with my
stepdad and my mom i currently drive a
2018 sport escape and i owe about
a little over thirteen thousand dollars
left on it
plus i have a student loan that
i have 11 grand left to pay on
i feel kind of stuck because my stepdad
doesn't think i should sell
my car to pay off my loan
in full um and i thought it would be a
good idea but
they don't think so so what do you think
i should do
how old are you i'm 27
and what do you make
can i give you a salary or does it have
to be what's your household income what
would you make if you didn't live
there what's your income uh as of right
now i make
i make uh 13 an hour 40 hours a week
so okay and you're only working 40 hours
a week
yes yeah so what are you making 25 30
000 a year right
i would say so yes what do you do i work
in a greenhouse it's actually a place
where we grow lettuce for grocery stores
so it's cool yeah okay what's your
long-term career plan um
i'm not 100 sure what i want to do but
um
i'm just trying to focus on the debt and
just tackle it
with as much as i can okay
um and your step dad and mom are not
multi-millionaires i take it
no they're not i worry about them
sometimes yeah
okay with their retirement i do too
because they don't have any money
because they've had car payments their
whole life
and that's the advice they're giving you
and so we really uh they're sweet people
and they're giving you a place to live
we want to respect that
but they're financial advice you don't
take financial advice from broke people
no even if they're people you love and
you love and you respect them otherwise
and all that kind of stuff and so
you know we just don't do that so um
what would be wrong with you just moving
out and selling your car
that's a good point i never thought of
that
i just i i as a dad i have trouble with
someone who won't take my advice staying
under my roof so i hate to tell you to
not take his advice and stay under his
roof
right but his advice is wrong you're i
agree with you on that but i also
want to respect the fact that he's
providing you shelter and so and none of
this is in a panic because you're not
completely broke or something you can
just
make a plan and say you know over the
next 90 days i'm going to save up some
money i'm going to work extra you're
only working 40 hours just kick in your
hours pick up an extra job doing
something
and pile up some money and get you a
little apartment and sell the truck
right i have about a little over
almost four grand in my savings i wanted
to save up for
something perfectly good that's used and
i think that seems logical
yeah that's great that's logical and it
gets you out of you know and i think you
got to work on your career side long
term
because i don't you don't want to be 53
working in the greenhouse 13
because you didn't ever do anything it
didn't ever move up in your world right
whatever your world is i don't care move
up in it
and let's start doing that but you know
you start setting some career goals and
start saying some things
something happens when you move out
whether you're 27 or whether you're 22
or whatever something happens in your uh
you know it's just like it's kind of
like when they let go of the seat of the
bicycle you better pedal
you know because you're gonna fall
freaking over if you don't right so
you've got a pedal and that's it's good
for you to pedal like that
i don't know john what are you thinking
i think you got to move out this sounds
like a broader
issue to it we're talking about a car
payment but it's not about that it's
about being 27
still making 13 bucks an hour still
being comfortable and like you said dave
i love that analogy you got to get off
the bike and just start pedaling
yeah let them let go of the seat and
it'll be good for them too
and um you know you don't have to be
disrespectful to them
in this regard i mean i have friends
that don't know how to vote and i'm not
disrespectful for them
i just float the wrong way i still love
them but i can
you know and i have people that disagree
with on you know lots of things but i
can be respectful to them and kind to
them but that doesn't mean i have to
follow their advice or go along with
whatever they tell me i have to do
especially moms and dads that
you know are doing the best they can
yeah but the only tools they got in
their toolbox right yeah
but i mean if you know if you want to
eat healthy and your mom's 400 pounds
and she doesn't think that's a good idea
then
you probably need to eat healthy right
or your coach is not doing there you go
get nutrition advice from somebody else
exactly i mean that's just you can't you
can't do that and so
um that's what you're facing so you got
some career stuff going on you got some
debt stuff going on and you got some
moving out stuff going on
and the three of those are going to work
together to completely change your life
in the next 12 months
it's going to be amazing yeah and that's
i love what you said there's nobody's in
a panic nothing's on fire but start
saving your money and get out four
thousand dollars you can probably start
working on looking for a place right now
and then
you know use a thousand of that to get
moved out and then save you up a
thousand and get rid of the escape and
you know
yeah um amazing you should go on
vacation more you come back
you come back a poet man that's
fantastic
yeah hardly but yeah yeah so i mean that
that's the thing
and um so yeah
i i i always hesitate to tell somebody
to disobey someone who they're living
with you know and to not respect their
uh
advice and so really tantamount with
selling the
escape is you really need to be out of
there because it's being
you know he's telling you and he's
furnishing you a place to live and so
i don't know how toxic that advice is or
how controlling it is or whether it's
just a casual thing i think you'd be
silly sell a truck you know
or if you sell the truck i'm throwing
you out you know i don't know which
which version of this we've got
but um i think it all comes back to who
you're giving a vote to right who you're
giving
permission to speak into your life and
as long as you live under somebody's
roof and you're eating their food and
using their electricity and water
they own you there's a thing that goes
with that that's right that's the thing
that goes
if you aren't using mine yeah you would
go by my rules while you're exactly
right that's how this is you're not
gonna
you know we go to church on sunday we
don't do drugs we don't sleep around
these are what ramsay that under my roof
do
you know it's that simple you don't want
to be at my house and you have to be in
my house get your own
that's how this works